as machine learning has taken off in the
last few years the increased demand for
specialised computing resources for
training and prediction has led to the
development of tensor processing units
or TP use but where did they come from
and how do they work on the inside stay
tuned to find out
[Music]
welcome to AI adventures where we
explore the art science and tools of
machine learning my name is Yu Feng Guo
and on this episode we're going to begin
a two-part adventure into the world of
high-performance computing at Google in
the first episode we'll look at the
original TPU its design and how it came
to be used in everything from google
photos to google translate then in the
second episode we'll talk about TPU v2
and v3 and learn about how they work to
enable the next generation of machine
learning
the trouble with modern computing is
that we keep wanting more processing
power unfortunately we're beginning to
run into the very limits of physics at
least this is very true for
general-purpose processors which is what
you might find in your everyday laptop
or smartphone the need for more specific
computational power is what led to the
first tensor processing unit to be
created understanding the original
designs that the TPU and why it was
built that way can help us as we look
forward
towards designing machine learning
architecture and software systems in the
future
the first tensor processing unit was
built as a PCI Express expansion card
and it was plugged straight into
existing server racks in Google data
centers it had a 700 megahertz clock
speed and had 40 watts of power
consumption and it's been in production
since 2015
powering things like search translate
photos and of course famously featured
in the alphago match in South Korea not
only was the TPU v1 much more
performance than the existing CPUs and
GPUs of the time it importantly had a
much higher performance per watt
energy these two effects combine to make
the first TPU a very effective chip the
chip featured an architecture that was
specific for deep learning it utilized
reduced precision a matrix processor and
a minimal design to reduce overhead
let's look at each of these now in turn
neural networks boil down to a rich set
of matrix multiplications and additions
the team decided to reduce the precision
of the chip using just 8 bit integers
rather than the conventional 32-bit
floating-point numbers and using a
technique called quantization they could
convert or map 32-bit floating-point
numbers to 8-bit integers so this
allowed significantly more integer
multiplier units to be fit into a single
chip so speaking of which let's talk
about that matrix processor conventional
processing systems read and write to
memory very often sometimes after every
single operation this is because they do
general-purpose processing so in order
to support many different kinds of
operations the hardware design must
necessarily be fairly generic however
this leads to bottlenecks due to all of
those memory accesses back and forth so
what if we could build a special-purpose
processor that performed a much more
limited set of operations but did so
more quickly this is what the TPU tries
to do with its matrix processor it uses
what's called a systolic array in order
to do a large hard-wired matrix
calculation without memory access one
analogy I've seen used to describe this
is that a CPU is like printing out
letters one by one stamping them out
whereas a GPU is printing on a whole
line at the time while a TPU it's
stamping out entire pages at a time the
core of the TPU is a huge systolic array
performing up to 250 thousand operations
per clock cycle
most of the chip is dedicated to this
matrix multiplication followed by
addition operations even though the
clock speed is
seemingly poultry 700 megahertz it is
performing a ton of operations every
clock cycle and one final note about all
of this is that it is important to
remember that in order to achieve this
design the TPU version one only did
predictions now you can't get your hands
on the TPU v1 or even use it directly
but every time you use something like
Google photos or Google Translate
there's probably a TPU powering your
search somewhere on the next episode of
AI adventures will talk about the TPU v2
and v3 and how they work and how to get
your code to run on a teepee you don't
miss it thanks for watching this episode
of cloud AI adventures and if you
enjoyed it be sure to click that like
button and subscribe to get all the
latest episodes right when they come out
if you're hungry for more TP u v1 action
you can read the paper that the team
published about the TPU I've linked to
it in the description down below